how do you straddle and how do you
manage that and and is it is it you know
what's your workflow like to go can you
slip in and out of these two different
very highly creative modalities of
thought one I think you would agree
right that theoretical physics is
incredibly creative and so is jazz music
and improvisation and also writing so
take us through those three different
you know kind of tripartite aspects of
your of your nature well I'm gonna be a
probably the first they'll probably be
the first time I admit this on any
podcast I've done a few since write in
my book and I'm cluesive exclusive to
the Infineon possible podcast yeah so I
would say like internally I don't I
don't actually feel that like you know
when we think about the classic being
smoked like you know this person can you
know yeah accumulate information or you
know can it can master these technical
things or is it I've always felt like
and like I don't feel smart in that way
alright and what I've managed to do I
think my hack is I've managed to engage
in things naturally I would say I'm
actually attuned to attracted to you and
figure out a way to weave them into each
other in a way that if you cut one of
those one of those links they all fall
apart so for example you know you you
know that I you know I used to I was a
serious runner and I you know I've 100
meters right 49 399 meters that's right
you know 400 N 800 and cross-country and
like so I was really into that but a lot
of times I found that my runs was
exactly that place going on that our
long run where I can really get deep
into a problem and just like the not
have the the self evident that would
come out of just if you're sitting at a
desk right because you're running you're
not going to be editing yourself too
much right you gotta not worry about not
slipping on ice and all that you know my
muse
right so and then my my physics they're
all they're kind of like one activity
lends itself to the other such that if I
stop one I will feel it you know I will
see a negative effect with the others so
I've kind of come up with a system for
myself where I'm the kind of like you
know jack of those trades and really I
don't feel like I'm a master of any of
those right and and and those three
things they cycle between each other
their days where I'll probably play
practice more these days I'm practicing
more my saxophone and you know studying
my music and some days I'll be thinking
more about a physics problem other days
I might be I might be right in but
they're usually all integrated with each
other and if like you cut one of those
things off the others will suffer I
always see it an impertinent written
that the human brain is actually not as
good as we think about multitasking and
you know especially when things are very
disparate like you know it's one thing
to be writing an email or something and
then you know turn your attention to
writing a lay tech you know code for a
paper but it's another thing to be you
know practicing you know I don't know
what you guys do and jazz musicians but
you must do scales or something like
that and then go and sit down and write
down you know a two-dimensional izing
model you know expansion as applied to
some you know very intricate calculation
and in theoretical physics can you do
that or is it more like well one day
I'll spend time on writing and and the
other time I'll you know and then a day
later or some other half of the day I'll
do you know jazz or do hardcore physics
how do you approach it is it separated
in time or space or both yeah they're
separate in common I don't multicast I
unlike our friend Jim Gates he claims
that be a really good multitasker I you
know I'm horrible at that actually I'll
be thinking about thinking about a
problem I'm thinking about like what
kind of problem is worthy pursuing or
all their problems to work on right so
sometimes be as simple as like what
should we be working I should I be
working on you know what's not already
been done what are the low-hanging
fruits right just a strategy of even
finding a problem
you know I actually want to turn that
question back to you when I'm done
saying what I have to say and sometimes
and sometimes you know like I'm I hate
to admit this but I'm an impatient
person and because I'm impatient what
ends up happening is I get very
frustrated and then I stifle my own
creative and even technical you know
abilities so a simple act of going off
and doing something else that is come
that might might be a parent appear to
be orthogonal to that mode right so if I
go play my sax and I just like work on a
scale or work on you know cadence or
whatever attitude or what-have-you right
long blown blown long tones like facing
the wall with saxophone and just blown a
long note for like as long as you can
and just repeat in that flow over and
over again there's something about doing
that about kind of vacillating between
those things that kind of I don't know
like contributes I don't know the right
word is but I don't clear I don't I
don't want to claim that there's a flash
of genius or insight but somehow like at
least it gives me a little bit more
energy or you know my patient tank fills
up a little bit more so I'm able to go
back to that problem or go back to that
confusion and look at it with fresh eyes
mm-hmm
and so so for me it's important to have
these other hobbies or things that I do
that appear to be orthogonal to you know
to each other ah and I found that to be
also the case for some other friends I
mean you're a pilot so I was wondering
if like a similar thing happens for you
yeah I think there's different aspects
of it where you can help to enter into
what your colleague at Brown University
Jed Brewer who's a addiction
psychologist and psychiatrist MD ph.d
and he talks about this flow state and
how people have gotten into it and
obviously it's it's it's a state of
extreme pleasure once one is inside of
such a state
when he talks about how you know you can
kind of pregame the brain to be
receptive to do so - in order to do
practical things so it's you know
creativity of a physics equation that
describes you know 10 dimensional
space-time might not have very many
applications in the real world of any
but but if you're struggling with you
know smoking addiction he will then
recommend to you this exploration of the
curious mind this the state of flow that
is sort of engaged by the parallel trait
of curiosity which is as far as we know
the way that we express creative
curiosity is unique on the arthur c
clarke centers you know podcast into the
impossible we like to talk about how can
you actually train the mind train for
curiosity and stimulate the mind to do
these things and is it possible or is it
really fundamentally different the type
of creativity that you have as a
saxophonist versus the creativity that
you have as a jazz musician obviously
the jazz of physics makes a case that
there are commonalities between the two
but let's take it a step further all
right you know is there a commonality
with experimental physics you know is it
is it the Zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance or is there something
endemic to the art of experimental
science you know versus a theoretical
science it's just different that no it's
not possible to get the same kind of
flow state or whatever as an
experimentalist as a theorist would
explore yeah I disagree that I think I
think my experience trying to be an
experimentalist and I failed at it it
was more experimental biophysics x-ray
crystallography remember when I had that
money and one of the things I saw was
sort of like the there's there's
theoretical work also going on and it's
because you have to now cleverly
remember there was this one guy in our
class he didn't stay around long but he
once said and expert a great
experimentalist is able to tease out
nature secret able to reveal in her
secrets right yeah this idea that like
you know there are these hidden things
and how do you this design a match
trick right yeah that's kind of like a
really brilliant experiment is that you
know you have to now imagine and
theorize before you even get on and and
build us the breadboard right there is
this kind of like theorizing and
figuring out okay how do I fool nature
all right and how do i how do i rewire
nature to reveal to reveal the unseen
right look at manifests so I think that
there is a very similar it's I think
it's coming from the same source really
really brilliant experiments and I would
love to see you right up here your
second book should be about that should
be about the genius of life like you
know we often talk about the genius of
how Fineman took the rocks i'm amplitude
and turned it into the final path
integral like you know let us talk about
the genius of like the power replica
experiment and like these designs that
that like made fury real